[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and executive
producers
george r martin will also serve as
executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood
volume 1
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary egg and the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
that's fire and blood vol 1. the atana
released fire and blood vol 2 will
continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon iii
is reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
the key event of the show is also the
key in the history of house targaryen
the dance of the dragons
the targaryen civil war the dance of the
dragons was the most devastating war in
the history of the seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his half sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first throne
both of them thought they belonged on
the armed round when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens
brothers fought brothers dragons for the
dragons
by the time it was over thousands were
dead one of the key characters in the
targaryen civil war is queen alison
alison hightower was a member of house
hightower who became the second wife to
king viserys the first targaryen
and therefore a queen of the targaryen
dynasty she was the daughter of seroto
hightower
who had been the hand of the king to
jahiris the first viserys the first
and later his grandson aiken ii she was
the mother of king aegon ii
queen hilina prince aymond and prince
daron
alice and hightower was in many ways the
true leader of aegon ii's faction
during the dance of the dragons alison's
father
otto hightower had been the hand of the
king in the last few years
of the long reign of king jaharis the
first targaryen
in 101ac otto brought the young alicent
to the royal court
where she cared for the aging king
jaehaerys eventually died in 103ac
while alicent was reading to him and was
succeeded by his grandson viserys the
first
alison stayed at court as her father
continued to occupy the position as the
hand under jaehaerys's grandson and
successor
king viserys the first targaryen already
early in the reign of viserys sir otto
and prince daemon targaryen were at odds
with each other
and the court full mushroom has
suggested that the quarrel between the
two men began when daemon deflowered
elecent
the truths of these tales have never
been uncovered visery is the first first
queen
emma rayne only produced one living
child before her death
a daughter rhaenyra in the years that
followed alice and caught the eye of
king viserys the first targaryen
and wizard chose alicent as his second
wife they married in 106
ac despite the whispers of people who
believed that the hand had risen above
himself
some doubt they tell his sense virtue as
rumors began circling that she had given
her maidenhead to prince daemon
and had later even slept with king
viserys while queen emma was still alive
the notorious mushroom suggested that
alison had been intimate with the late
jaehaerys as well
nonetheless alicent was wed to his heirs
at first young rainer and ellison got
along well
but the rift grew between them as soon
as allison produced her own children for
viserys the first
and clearly wanting them to succeed to
the throne instead of her
ali sent bore viserys the first four
children aegon the second
aemon the one eye there on the daring
and helina who became the sister wife of
fagon ii
over the years of viserys since the
first reign despite his best efforts
a better rivalry grew between alice
saint and rainer at court
as well as between their rival factions
of supporters
in 111ac a great tourney was held at
king's landing
on the 5th anniversary of the king's
marriage to queen ellison
at the opening feast alison wore a green
gown while princess rhaenyra dressed in
targaryen red and black
soon afterward their respective
followers started dressing in similar
colors and styles
to display their political allegiance
rhaenyra's faction the princess's
followers wore black clothing
in dallas satisfaction the queen's
followers wore green clothing
ultimately this inspired the nicknames
for the two factions the blacks and the
greens
the blacks rhaenyra supporters included
the stark stallis
rayne starlis and villarians among
others
while the green salads and supporters
included the high towers and the
lannisters
among others the baratheons started out
as blacks
but switched to the greens when the
civil war began while the tyrells may
have been greens at first
but during the civil war itself declared
themselves neutral
when rhaenyra turned 16 the small
council started looking for a suitable
husband
alice said had her own choice her eldest
son prince sagan who while the princess
was 16 years old
was only 6 years old himself viserys
argued that the siblings had never
gotten along
but alison urged her husband that was
all the more reason to add it to
viserys refused believing the taliscent
only made the suggestion to get her own
blood on the throne
alice sends of the son aegon grew to be
a lazy man
prone to indulging his lusts with
mistresses
as well as prone to outbursts of anger
given the take on the second had no
great political skill it was his mother
alison who was seen as the true leader
of his faction
however he was not necessarily an
outright puppet as they shared the same
goals
alicent is the real political mastermind
behind her son
the dance of the dragons was seen so
much as a rivalry between princess
rhaenyra and queen ellison
that george r martin's prequel novella
about the conflict was titled the
princess and the queen
referring to the two of them instead of
to aegon ii
visery is the first publicly and
repeatedly made the great lords of the
realms fair oats that rhaenyra would
succeed him on the iron throne
as the first ruling queen a matter of
hours after viserys the first died in
his sleep however alison staged a coup
one that she had been long planning to
define details
one night a servant found the old king
had died in his sleep
and ran to inform queen elizand protocol
dictated that the bells would be run
everyone notified and the raven sent to
dragonstone to summon the
heir princess rhaenyra for her
coronation but ellie sent her daughter
plans
once she saw her that husband's body she
sealed the room and had the sermon
thrown into the black cells to ensure
his silence
according to mushroom who was away with
rhaenyra targaryen on dragonstone alice
and poisoned viserys's drink
true or not instead of announcing
viserys as the first death immediately
alison warned sir christian cole now
lord commander of the kingsguard
and together they called the small
council to discuss the succession
where plans were made to crown ellison's
son prince aegon
instead of princess rhaenyra who had
been viserys
heir of the seven men counsel including
her father
odo all were greens except for old
maester of coin lime and beesberry
alison soon made it clear that she
intended to crown aegen ii
against her late husband's fishes debate
did not
end till dawn when the master of coin
declared this to be treason
in response lord commander of the
kingsguard christian cole
silently snuck behind beastboy's chair
and without the word slashed his trout
as the old man bled out onto the council
table the remaining council members
seated around it
including ellis and continued to plan
out the next steps in their cook
her son rejected the iron throne at
first but was told by ellison that
rhaenyra would kill him and his siblings
if she was to become a queen
coronation ceremony was soon after held
for aegon ii and helina
aegon's sister wife in the dragonpit
while rhaenyra was crowned at
dragonstone
this rivalry exploded into a massive
civil war between their two rival
factions of house targaryen
a conflict known as the dance of the
dragons after the coronation
ellis sent moved her chambers to the
tower of the hand where her father
resided
every evening before bed queen hilina
brought her children to see their
grandmother
because the tower of the hand was less
secure than maeger's holdfast
blood and cheese hired by damon were
able to take advantage of this custom
they sneaked into alison's chambers slow
her bed made
and bound and gagged alison when healing
arrived with the children they slew
prince jacarys aegon's eldest son and
heir
as revenge for the death of rainer's son
luceries
healing us subsequently went mad with
grief
aegon gave his surviving son prince
mailer to his mother alicent to race
later in the war aim and targaryen
foolishly led the green army defending
king's landing north
to strike against herrenhall leaving the
capital with only a skeleton defense
rhaenyra's forces were then able to take
king's landing in a surprise assault
with rhaenyra herself leading from
dragon back
the city awards supported rhaenyra as
they were loyal to daemon
and threw the gates open to her army and
also killed a few green officers that
aegon ii
had installed to command them including
alison's own brother grain
aegon ii was sneaked out of the city in
secret
several members of the green council
however were captured and
executed as shaders among them alison's
father otto
ellison was also captured and rhaenyra
came to meet her
despite the bitter rivalry between the
two rhaenyra announced that for the
memory of the love of her father she
would spare ellison's life
during the exchange between the two
queens alice sent made references to an
old rumor
stating that rainer's first three sons
were not legitimate targaryens
but the bastards from sir harvey strong
according to septon eustace and grand
maester monken rhaenyra furious at this
accusation
threatens alicent to have her tongue
removed if she continued to spread its
lie again
according to mushroom rainier's mistress
of whisperers and demons former lover
miseria dissuaded her from taking
ellison's tongue
and instead suggested another terrible
punishment
but also more poetic alison and her
daughter should be sent to the street of
silk
to work as ladies of night mazaria
reportedly told rhaenyra
let them remain there until they are
with child they speak of bastard so
freely
let him each have one of their own
moreover mushrooms cited this event as
the cause of ellison's total decision to
end it all
as she probably got pregnant rhaenyra
remained in control of the capital for
about half a year
but through several surprising turns of
events rhaenyra had to withdraw from the
city
and the greens recaptured it as the
armies of the lads and the lord craig
and stark
advanced on the capital plotters plotted
against aegon ii
the king was found poisoned and alicent
was arrested by valerians
aegon ii had captured and fed rhaenyra
to his dragon before his
own death rhaenyra targaryen's son took
the throne as zagon iii targaryen in 131
ac
during the hour of the wolf lord craig
and stark punished all men who betrayed
king aight in the second
and allison while creagan was rhaenyra's
supporter and had believed that taking
the second had been a usurper
and had been riding south to oust him
from power
lord stark did not believe in killing
him but rather in defeating him on the
field of battle
alison survived through the end of the
war but at great cost
all four of her children and
grandchildren had died therefore alison
lived to see her own bloodline end
alicent remained in her chambers for the
last year of her life
alice sent often wept began talking to
herself and came to dislike the color
green
she died in 133 ac during the outbreak
of winter fever
20 major battles on land in the sky and
on the sea
even more smaller battles and even more
betrayals turn cloaks and twists
all of that in more this game of thrones
prequel show house of the dragon brings
in 2022
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comments section down below
thank you so much for watching and i
hope to see you in the next one
peace